foreign
[Music]
racing actually because the first part
of the Season had been really busy and
uh
I kind of just needed a break in a
trading block so I didn't really know
how I was going to be going and um
it was a really successful week but you
obviously started off really well
winning the prologue did you expect to
win the prologue did you have any
Ambitions to win that or was it purely
by surprise I knew I knew it was going
to be good because it was like it suited
me a while and from time to a bike and
stuff I've been working a lot
but I never really expected to win
especially of the guys that were there
so um cross the line and saw my time and
had a little bit of time to wait in the
hot seat and uh it was really a bit of
surprise to be honest yeah but really
satisfying at the same time
what do you call about
um you're fueling for a time trial type
student when do you start to think about
it I think one thing with the time chart
is is
you only do a five minute race or
however long the time travel that was
five minutes that day but um you're
almost out and about for the whole day
you know you're going to do the course
reading in the morning and
it is important to actually feel quite a
lot more than you might think for a five
minute effort and then
make sure your sugar's high and you're
ready to go um
for the rest it feels longer than a four
or five hour road it could be you know
when you think about all day and
especially this prologue in Romney the
corners were quite a key part of the
course and um trying to nail those
really
imagine Each corner so you're about to
hit them at full speed yeah and what
types of things do you like to eat on a
time trial day like for breakfast or in
the previous meal as an example
maybe an omelette with plain pasta or
something right or maybe some Parmesan
and Oliver and salt so yeah no actual
sauce or anything so it's quite um it's
quite plain and easy on the stomach
and then you almost start looking at
that surround the time you do your
Recons or start taking stuff like
caffeine in the bicarb we take for short
efforts like that as well and
there's a lot of stress in the stomach
yeah yeah so nice and light really and
functional foods if you like yeah trying
to keep it um simple and
the last thing you want is stomach
distress as you're trying to do a
warm-up or think about the course or
talk us through the nutritional strategy
for that type of States because of
course that's a more traditional Road
cycling stage so what does it look like
from the morning time right through to
crossing the Finish Line it wasn't it
was it finished in the Sprint this stage
but it was actually quite a hard day
yeah it's quite important the fueling
all day you know and it's rolling and
um
a couple of shorter climb just before
the Finish where yeah we also plan to go
quite hard so
it's not like a some easy sprint as you
roll along and you can really Cruise
along in the bunch and you don't have to
fuel too much but
that was a good breakfast
um on the kitchen truck of our chefs
yeah
quite lucky to have that and then uh
High fueling all day really on the bike
yeah I usually start with porridge and
fruit and then
um have an omelette with bread or toast
or something and or pancakes even after
that so if I started like a 40 drink
yeah and consume solids in the first
couple of hours and then uh
usually this one has made rice cakes or
paninis or something like that and then
um
switch to more gels and
stronger energy drinks at times yeah
maybe some caffeine an hour or so before
the Finish
so we're always advising Riders to have
X amount of grams of carbohydrate as an
example can you remember how many grams
fuel The Ride Like That my guess would
be 80 to 100 yeah in the final so it's
the super high days then yeah well
there's not many
um personally I think anyway there's not
many
easy races anymore yeah there's a couple
of Sprint days where I guaranteed spring
but yeah
the breakaways are going so fast these
days the bunch has to ride quite hard to
catch them and you're just always
working hard
um and you want to hit the Finish as
fresh as possible so yeah you keep
topped up I've not done many easy races
so yeah
you always want to be ready for um
it's about your best effort when it
comes to it yeah and have you any
specific or favorite science of sport
products that you use to fuel those days
the 40 drink is quite neutral and easy
to drink I think yeah and stay on top of
hydration the jellies are a nice new
touch if you're getting sick of
everything else
yeah yeah the good swap with other teams
who quite like them as well so we often
talk about the importance of fueling and
perhaps what's overlooked is recovery
what actually recovery can be the
difference between winning and losing as
well do you have any Reflections on the
role of recovery and supporting your
stage race performances
you're almost your most important meal
there's your
even after trading there's your lunch
and stuff to be um
well we always do a high club lunch
pretty much every day of my training and
um
really maximize recovery maximize what
you've done in the training if you
missed that first little window and you
get a bit hungry you never really I'm
hungry for the next day really so yeah
and looking forward to 2023 any
particular goals or Ambitions for the
season kind of got a rough idea and um I
think I'm on the longest for the tour
again which would be yeah amazing if we
could start there and um and then the
words are in Glasgow yeah uh Road and
track so that'd be um
that'd be amazing I think that'd be a
good turnout for that yeah okay well
thanks very much thanks a lot